listen before we start this I already
know what you're gonna say I'm wearing
the same [ __ ] shirt this is an old
thing how come you're talking about it
now because you guys asked for it so I'm
doing it get off my band hey what is
going on YouTube as I said earlier I
realized that this is a little bit late
but once again because it keeps flooding
my [ __ ] I'm gonna talk about it because
I love you when you guys send topics and
when you guys send articles trust me I
listen something like I give a little
[ __ ] of that I'll [ __ ] of that who we
talking about today Kim Kardashian you
guys might know her as the girl who got
famous from taking a huge chocolate D
that's right I said it
and you know every time I make that joke
people like I can't believe you said bad
[ __ ] like it's not true what the [ __ ]
yeah it wasn't Lee [ __ ] you ain't been
in me acting like you didn't try to
download that [ __ ] on a Windows computer
and you got multiple viruses and you
lost everything but recently or not so
recently Kim Kardashian got robbed of
over nine million dollars in jewelry
where was it my friends in we Pepe
according to this article she got robbed
after she left a very very intimate
party in Paris there was truffle
scrambled eggs white fish and shut bein
a busy bay by the article what tell us
this stupid [ __ ] information that has
nothing to do with her getting robbed
the suspects allegedly broke into the
luxurious places she was staying at tied
her up
gagged her didn't harm her at all and
left with three accomplices this is 4
this is 3 anybody who gets robbed in
their [ __ ] I feel terrible but for basic
folks like me it's kind of hard to feel
bad for somebody who got robbed worth
the [ __ ] that's worth more than my whole
existence so Kim K can I ask you
something what the [ __ ] are you doing
walking around with [ __ ] worth a jet
plane we call that it invite to get
robbed you're a celebrity Roberts don't
give a [ __ ] about who you are or maybe
they give a real big [ __ ] about who you
are you shouldn't be walking around with
that [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you think
was gonna happen
give me your money I'm Kim Kardashian
bill I did not now no [ __ ] with your
dumbass looking like a French target and
with a [ __ ] with your bodyguards
according to this article as well
apparently you do have bodyguards but
you don't take them seriously I'll get
it
once you faint my brother cuz you marry
somebody from Chicago they scared of you
in France it's Paris my buckle I don't
know [ __ ] about shot setting people at
branding Chicago was a shitty pizza
joint shikaka
and even if Kanye was there what the
[ __ ] was he gonna do I loved him but
what a drive-by meltdown
I am Walt Disney Ralph Lauren Bill Gates
Ash Ketchum Allah I love that boat now
if this really did happen mrs. Bob
Parker what West I'll [ __ ] another my
deepest condolences it must have been
absolutely frightening but why is it
that a bit of this feels like it's kind
of a publicity stunt everything just
happens to clean it was like the scene
of taken
they just ball gagged you didn't run so
it wasn't a ball get with it for me
because you're known for your publicity
stunts it just doesn't seem believable
but if it is I'm Sally it just makes me
question why somebody like you who is of
high importance and has a lot of money
will go into a foreign country without
taking the necessary precautions to
protect yourself specifically an area
that has a lot of violence recently
something's not adding up I'm
questioning it I don't know but what do
you guys think do you think she's faking
the funk or is this real hmm I don't
[ __ ] have that hey what is going on
youtube if you up [ __ ] my finger so
remember new videos every Thursday 3
p.m. and Sundays at 12 p.m. and this is
probably a bonus video if not sure I'll
see you guys then follow me on instagram
twitter and everything else I'll see
y'all there go for broke apparel you
guys can go ahead and copy [ __ ] we're
working on some new [ __ ] we're gonna
have a castle release soon [ __ ]
and on top of that y'all can't wait to
that next year line
baby big things popping like that like a
like a like a like a non-bank sign
[Applause]